I was going guys welcome to a new video
on code Tecna toriel's today I want to
talk about open shot of video editor
this is a free editor that runs on
pretty much any OS and I use it
occasionally and just wanted to go over
it make people aware of it and
apparently sounds off alright so this is
their websites open shot org this is an
open source project so you can go find
this on github I think do they even have
a link somewhere maybe they do oh it is
on github you can just search it I guess
get open shot you'll find it there it is
so this is a program that you can go and
prove if you have issues with it and
don't worry there are tons of issues
this needs a lot of work but it is
functional enough to actually use so
I've already downloaded it I'm gonna go
ahead and launch it and just give you
guys a walkthrough I've used this quite
a bit so I know the majority of stuff
you can do and can't do and it's a
little both I may just search for it
here open shot there we go we're gonna
run it and we'll go ahead and I'm just
gonna give you guys a bit of a rundown
of what I found works great and what I
found doesn't work hardly at all so when
you open it up this is what you get you
get this interface I'm using Windows
here if you're using like Linux or Mac
your experience may vary I can't really
speak for its functionality on those but
I can't speak horse functionality on
Windows alright so I'm kind of also
gonna go over everything you need to
know to get a project going
so obviously you open it up you get an
untitled project you get a little hot
bar here your usual stuff up here of
menus and you'll see your project files
are here you've got transitions you've
got effects in my experience these
transitions effects don't really work so
maybe it's better on Linux maybe was
better on Mac but on Windows it
basically just glitches out and does a
bunch of weird stuff to your video so
that sucks but maybe they work better
for some other people maybe I'm doing
something wrong I'll give it a try
and we'll see if we can get them to work
okay so first thing we want to do is we
want to bring in a video files so you
can do this with the drag-and-drop
and then I'll just start going through
stuff and see alright whatever we'll
just do this one this is this is some
magic together in arena video okay so
you bring in a track you can move it
around here you get all the properties
for whatever you have selected now the
properties don't work like you think
they do first of all the the auto
timeline or auto what's the word
keyframe if you change something here
it just keyframes it based on like just
started the video to where you are now
so if I go if I'm like messing with my
video and I think oh I just want this
track to be lower and I lower this
volume that's not what it does so that's
really annoying it's probably the most
annoying thing like what this actually
does is it lowers the volume from the
start to here so it goes full as you can
see the volume changing it starts at one
its keyframes it in wherever you press
it so super obnoxious does it with
everything you can sometimes barely use
this editor because of that it's just
key framing things when you don't expect
it to anyway that's my experience so how
do you get rid of that I don't I don't
even know I don't even know how to take
off this keyframe this editor is a mess
but at least it sort of works there's
probably an easy way to do it I don't
know how to do it exactly I think you
got to go to volume and reset volume and
that does it but other than that I don't
know so if you've keyframed a bunch you
can't just change them you have to like
reset them all I could be wrong but yeah
that's super obnoxious makes it really
hard to work with and it's like that
with everything you want to crop you
want to do any of this stuff your key
framing it all the time and there's no
other option apparently so please
correct me if I'm wrong cuz that drives
me nuts and I could I can barely use
this thing because of that it's about
the worst keyframing i've ever seen
so let me show you just a couple other
things i'm just going to kind of go over
what i would usually do and
and we'll go from there so usually you
want to see the wave form of your audio
that way you can kind of tell the quiet
and loud parts of your video and let's
see and also of course you can zoom in
and out with this it's really really
really really really really really slow
like you want to zoom in you click this
you wait you click this you wait it's
going kind of fast right now but and you
can see how long it's keyframe and over
there or however long it's supposed to
be showing you so this seems to be going
really fast right now but yeah once
you've done a few things in your project
these buttons are now they turn into
like I don't know wait till you I don't
know they just take forever you click
one you go to the kitchen get a drink
make some food come back hope it's done
just change in the zoom as all does okay
so naturally I'm gonna rag on this
program because it has annoyed me so
much but it does do some good things
there are some good things about this
and I will get to those you just kind of
have to know what is crappy because if
you just jump in and start using this
it's gonna drive your nuts and you're
gonna uninstall it right away so if I
I'm thinking if I get all the annoying
stuff out of the way you at least know
what to avoid or what to expect and you
can get actual use out of it okay so
let's show the waveform of this audio
now this is yet another crappy thing but
at least it sort of works so if you
right-click on your video you can go to
display waveform and then you get this
little hourglass thing and you wait this
takes I don't even know how long we
could be here minutes we could be here
hours this takes for freaking ever it
doesn't matter how big or small your
video is apparently the whoever's
programming this didn't take algorithms
courses because they picked the slowest
algorithm ever to do this so shame on
you
maybe you should improve it or something
I don't know or we could improve it like
I said this is open source so I guess we
can't really complain much because it's
like
you know you can go you can just go fix
it so I shouldn't be complaining
I should go fix it except no cuz it'll
take me way too much time to do that I
don't even know where to look where to
start but it is being updated this will
improve
maybe maybe me making this video will
contribute to that a little bit so at
least the developer or developers know
what is super annoying about this
program and what needs to be fixed so
anyway we go back here
we're still waiting this will be a while
I guess I'm just gonna sit here and do
nothing until it's done because I can't
even go to the next part
so what do you guys think you know this
would be a perfect time to like this
video and leave a comment let me know
what you think and yeah craziness I
guess I can undo other stuff so usually
when I'm editing video with this I
usually have something else open and and
I'm doing something else just because it
takes so long to process anything that
you literally can't sit here and wait it
just doesn't make sense you might as
well have something else to do in all
this downtime of the crappy algorithms
well sigh alright so let's just uh maybe
extend this out let's say is actually
working okay so this is a 17 minute
video it's not a very heavy video it's
like half a gig maybe in 17 minute video
that's only half a gig is a pretty
lightweight video so so here we are
waiting waiting I click show waveform I
wait I'd love to show you more of this
but this is literally what it's like
editing with this you just have to wait
a lot and you just have to deal with
it's just complete awkwardness but hey
well there goes it I did it okay so now
you can see your waveform down there now
it's really tricky to do something like
change your audio level because you got
to make sure your little timeline thing
here is at the very beginning of your
video or before it because like I said
when you change your tuck of this volume
it timelines it in wherever you are so
if you want to double the volume of
everything you gotta go before the video
starts and do it that way it actually
increases the volume throughout the
whole track the whole thing so sometimes
this is handy say you got one part right
here where you want to make quiet you
can I don't actually don't know how to
do this because I feel like if I change
it it's gonna take it from the beginning
and change it to here yeah it is which I
don't want say I just want one section
to get quiet and get loud again that's
really freaking hard
really I guess I could go here too right
yeah I guess you got to do the end one
first because if I make this to it
should then you know stay level two all
throughout here then from here on go
down to one and then we could go from
there maybe we want to go back up to two
then we got that sound change timeline
it's a little awkward a little different
than most but it does it does seem to
function okay now it doesn't always
function okay
the audio sometimes when you render it
comes through choppy and scratchy and
really weird so it's it's not very
reliable and especially if you're
layering things okay but it does if
you're doing very simple things it
usually does okay so I will say that and
you know I did I talked about blender as
a video editor and
blender is a little bit more reliable
but this one sort of has a better play
like when you hit play on blender the
audio never synchronizes right and
that's super annoying but at least with
this program when you hit play you're
actually getting the audio that's at
this part of the video so it's a little
easier to line up things so that's nice
but still it has its annoyances all
right so let's let's go into a few other
things I want to talk a little bit about
Larry so there are a few little handy
handy things that come with this like
this title you can go to title and click
it and you get some templates of just
like little things you can drop into
your video these are a bit clunky
sometimes I said sometimes pretty much
after you've added one they start
getting really really really slow so say
you like this design you want to say
hello there now as you noticed already
typed and it's still trying to process
my typing I don't know why it's so slow
but it just lags behind and in this
thing all the time and it only gets
worse as you continue on and you see the
file name here yeah if you don't change
this your projects overwrite each
other's files all the time so if you go
back to an old project suddenly your
titles are all weirdly changed it's
because they overwrite each other even
from different projects so that's like a
another just major epic fail on this you
can rename them to something unique so
they don't overwrite each other but it
you know if you if you're not then
they're gonna override each other as you
do more projects you can change the font
I'm not sure if this actually works
sometimes it seems to sometimes it
doesn't seems to work okay there you can
click this text to change the text color
it seems to work okay usually this
background so by default they have it I
don't know it shows it white but it's
not white obviously so I don't know what
this actually does or if it even works
but apparently
apparently now it's green it was black
before even though I had it set to it
was defaulting the white so I'm just
flat-out confused by how this works so I
think you got to bring it all the way
you know actually this would okay so
this looks good but it's actually not
because it will I'll show you here and
so if I drag this in now which works
decently well and go to it you'll see
that it covers over top of all my video
with this thing when you don't want it
to do that so what you have to do is you
can right-click on this and go to where
is it edit and once you edit you go to
background color you got to change this
outfit a zero for that background and
then you should be able to see through
it and you give it as expected so these
are a little wonky they don't don't work
quite as well as you would hope but they
do work so it can help out it can save
you time in your project and it's better
than nothing it's better than having to
make it in a separate program now I
think it uses a certain program to do
these to make these so for example if
you want to do your own custom edits you
can do to this advanced editor so if I
click this advanced editor it's going to
look for an install of Inkscape on my
computer and launch Inkscape with this
stuff so this is kind of cool it's not
it's not the worst thing so there goes
it just open Inkscape it's tempus VG and
if I change anything here and then hit
save it will reflect on here so that's
actually kind of a cool integration they
do I'm a Inkscape master but I'll just
put in some random stars and hit save
and then I'll closing escape and now you
can see it just reflects in the air so
that's actually a really nice feature
sometimes it works great sometimes it
doesn't so when you hit save it should
save and we can drop that in and now
we've got some more little random things
going on all right
so that's okay those for the most part
those titles seem to work decently other
than the overriding issue they're not
too bad so I guess you got to give them
unique names if you really care about
going back to the project alright so
let's look at these animated titles now
this is where just nonsense happens
some of these work some don't so it's
kind of a cool idea they want you to be
able to just easily make a little
animated titles and animated stuff but
the problem is most of these don't work
very well you do have to have a blender
installed it renders them with blender
and it goes up to 180 frames on this one
for example this is just some rotating
thing where you give it a title and give
some settings and when you hit render it
finds your install of blender and uses
blender to render this so sometimes this
works great sometimes it doesn't work at
all and your your results may vary this
one seems to be functioning but I've
tried some of the other ones and some of
the other ones just they either crash or
they just freeze they get stuck on a
frame and never continue any further so
these are kind of hit and miss but when
they do work it's it's handy it looks
like this one's just chugging away now
so yeah we'll let it do its thing I
really don't want to wait for this but I
highly doubt it's gonna let me cancel oh
it did okay amazing so this is actually
looking pretty good I know I've
complained a lot but when you actually
get into a real project it usually gets
really clunky really fast it's the big
problem so say you want to make a cut
right here
and the way you do that I good luck
figuring it out you basically have to
right-click on this head thing or press
one of these hotkeys and it doesn't cut
what you have selected it cuts what this
line is intersecting so it doesn't
matter what you have selected when you
do these cuts if you have multiple
things then it's over top of when you do
it in which the snapping won't even let
me do right here let's see I guess I
could drag out this edge and then I
could probably do it but if you right
click hit slice I'll keep both sides
with ctrl K it's gonna slice everything
this line is going through so now we got
two of them one over here one over here
and then you can drag these edges that
seems to function okay it does get a
little clunky as you go on further in
your project but that's just a way of
cutting things in and we consume this
back in and see what working with it now
another thing that happens when you
overlap things it try
- Auto fade and sometimes this works
great sometimes it doesn't work hardly
at all so for example if I grab this
other file and just drag it over it
tries to snap two edges sometimes that's
nice too
but when you overlap it automatically
puts a fade in there and this fade is
like a very specific fade let me see if
we can even see it on the screen I guess
you can probably see it yeah there it is
so starting to fade in the new one and
does its thing usually it does okay the
only problem is when you're doing these
fades the audio like makes this clicky
sounds like so it just messes up your
audio anytime you do these fades well
not anytime it seems to happen some of
the time so that's super annoying and I
have no clue how to get these
transitions to work reliably this Auto
fade that comes in seems to be okay and
that looks like and do some stuff with
it or just remove it but say you want to
put your own custom transition in there
like maybe you wanted to do what this
bar ripple effect good luck I don't know
how to get this to work like the obvious
thing to do would be to drag it over the
thing here and think okay maybe that's
gonna work but what ends up happening
let's see if it even works maybe it'll
work this time let's see if it does the
ripple thing
yeah this actually seems to be working
but usually what it does is it just
makes your screen flicker back and forth
between these two videos and it just
does this awkward like flicker thing
with your video so this seems to be
working now but I don't know I've done
projects before and had it all worked
out how I liked it and then when I
rendered it I got this awkward
flickering thing going on and it's like
what do you would he even do about that
and then and anytime you overlap
something they just Auto puts a new fate
and so sometimes it gets a little
annoying because it's like I don't want
it there so you gotta click it and
delete it yet again and then another
thing is how do you get this lined up
properly when you want to use a custom
one you've got to do this then you got
to drag it out and then it snaps to the
wrong place like you see the snap on
that side changed a little bit so now
it's not lined up and a who the heck
knows what it's doing anymore let's see
is it the right fade I don't know I
think it is I think this one's actually
doing well it's hard to tell on this
particular video but yeah so these
transitions they're just a little hit
and miss but they're they're cool play
around with them might as well see if
you can get them to work right it always
snaps slightly off where you tried to
snap it to so that's really annoying
because if you're trying to line things
up perfectly what you just can't it just
doesn't let you so that's that's been a
painstaking thing and now I don't know
what it's doing here let's see we go to
here to here to here I should be getting
this little board transition I guess
it's happening I can't really tell on
this you might be able to tell better
with different types of video but I know
I really ragdoll in these transitions at
least they're here you know lets you
play around with them but you'll find
out if you try they're just not that
reliable these effects I don't know how
to use these effects I've tried just
weird stuff happens once again you like
and I guess you drag it in I don't even
know what you do okay you drag it on top
of a video and it looks like it just
affects the whole video so now I've
turned this one into negative there we
go yeah that actually works pretty well
so if I do another cut here I'm just
gonna press ctrl K I'll bring in
pixelate on this one looks like you just
drop it on it pixelated yeah that's kind
of
I mean this these are kind of cool I
haven't played around with these a ton
but they seem to work okay so another
thing if you have some if you have some
cuts
let's do and also if you have a layer
with effects and you do cuts on it who
knows what's gonna happen now here's
where the slowdown happens I've done a
few things I've done like what four or
five things and now when I do a cut it
just it just freezes it just sits here
it's like trying to figure out how to
process a cut just takes forever it's
like come on come on I just pressed cut
I just pressed ctrl K you know the same
thing is right click and I can't even
right-click anymore it's just froze from
doing a cut so it'll do it from here on
out from now on
working with this project it's gonna be
super slow on every little thing I do
and this this is what really ruins the
program actually so say I want to zoom
out it's actually going kind of quick a
lot quicker than I would expect zoom in
that's not bad
alright so say you want to make a cut
and remove a piece of this obvious got
some little time frame there I don't
know to little green dot so apparently
it's time framing our key framing
something here I didn't I didn't try to
keyframe anything I don't know why it's
key framing something oh it's the volume
it's key framing the volume sound there
I don't know why I didn't I didn't ask
it to do that it's just doing it maybe
it's something that I don't know so just
some weird stuff happens sometimes that
you would never expect and couldn't
predict that's just how this program
works but I want to show you how to cut
there's other cuts so you can keep a
side so if I say keep right side it's
gonna cut off the left side and that's
super nice and a great time for a phone
call right when I'm in the middle
recording where was I I don't know
cutting okay oh yeah yeah so when you do
a cut like that you got to bring this
over and it snaps back over it's not too
bad so as you can see this kind of works
and you can you know you can do some
cool stuff it's just it's just got a few
glitches I've really been ragging on
this program but it's really not as bad
as make it sound it's just you can't
expect every little thing to work be
sure to save often when you're using
this program because occasionally just
crash and you can do that with this
little Save button right here safe
project and
prompt you and ask you very well save it
yada yada all right so when you're ready
to render I guess I've gone over enough
of this I feel like this is getting a
little long the basically when you're
ready to render you just hit this export
video and it's it's an automated thing
where it just renders from the beginning
to the end you don't you don't put in
your own keyframes or anything like that
you just press this button give it a
name it's gonna set your project name
and give it a folder path and you this
is kind of cool because you can do this
60fps it's got a bunch of different
profiles I haven't tested all these I've
really only done this one profile that
I'm showing here it does render pretty
quickly so that's nice it doesn't it
doesn't take as long as blender for
example and looks like it gives you the
start in in frames but it's it
automatically sets these I really
haven't had to mess with these too much
but you can if you want to looks like it
uses AAC audio and mp4 5x 264 so there's
the bitrate quality too and everything
so you can mess with this if you need to
but I generally don't and it seems okay
your results may vary
alright well I think I've talked enough
about this program and you know it's
really not as bad as it sounds I really
rag don it pretty hard just because it's
annoyed me but it has its uses it's it's
a bit user friendly it's free it's open
source so you can go fix things if you
want or whatever and well that's gonna
do it for this video thank you for
checking out a video on code tech
tutorials let me know what you think
about open shot let me know what you
think about videos like this where I
just kind of review software and talk
about my experience with it peace out
guys see you in the next one